Can you guys hear... the... the audio?
Can you guys hear it?
I can sometimes you can hear it.
Sometimes you cannot hear it.
Now you can hear the audio.
The gavel you got is cool?
I know!
Oido!
Oido in the court!
I don't want to hit it too hard.
I don't want to ruin it or have a break from my strength.
Oido!
Yeah, this is when you guys are being bad.
The bonk is gonna be real.
Stop being bad!
Sounds like there's nothing in your brain.
Your head is hollow.
Smells like wood.
The gavel does not smell like wood.
The base though, smells like wood.
Yummy.
Sniffer, sniffer.
Anyway.
Anyway, I put it on the ground.
I...
am singing!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh boy, I hope she plays Hot To Go.
Ashes, this is Minto's dream.
H-O-T-T-O...
You can take me hot to go.
Except, not today.
There's no...
Probably no English.
If it's English, it's gotta be anime English.
Five months, baby.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I hope my...
Earlier I was on Matara's stream and she was like, Wow girl, you sound raspy.
And I was like...
She was like, probably from like, all the recording.
We talked for like, literally like, six or seven hours yesterday.
She was probably from like, all the talking and all the recording.
And I was like, I sure hope I'm not raspy.
I have a karaoke tonight.
So, if I'm raspy, if my voice is bad, I'm so sorry.
Mr. Mel-chan, thank you for the 5k of debt.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Five months!
Otake time.
Sometimes otake, sometimes whatever.
I don't know.
Actually, I have no list at all.
I was just gonna go into here.
I didn't mean to click that.
Yeah, um...
Uh, uh, uh, uh...
What are these, though?
Sabikara?
Is that like, only singing the chorus?
That's kind of awesome.
That's kind of for me.
I feel like...
I never really do, like, themed karaoke.
Like, you know, this one's an Annie song, obviously.
But...
Um...
Because I always realize how much I don't remember of a song.
You know?
Or like, I only have listened to the...
Like, either I only listen to it at Annie Karaoke, or...
Or I only listen to it when it's playing in the show.
So I only know the TV size.
And then I'm like, oh, shoot, I don't know the whole song.
You know?
What is under Sabikara, though?
I wonder if it's a bunch of songs that people are...
Oh.
Peace sign?
That's peace sign, right?
This is, um...
Oh, gosh.
I can't...
That's the Honeyworks idol group, isn't it?
That's the one?
Yeah, I know it.
I know it!
Oh, Aquarian!
See that?
But I know that whole song.
I want to try and sing songs that I don't always sing.
But also...
It's hard.
Remembering so many songs, you know?
It's hard remembering so many songs.
Hanabi.
Fireworks songs.
Natsu Fest.
Summer songs.
Natsu Utau summer songs.
Game songs.
And then...
Wedding songs!
What's under game songs?
Oh.
I was like, I wish they would say what game they're from.
It literally has it on the far right.
I was like, this is probably...
Project...
Project Sekai.
What's it called?
What is it in...
What is the English...
Project Sekai...
What's it called in English?
Colorful Stains!
Do you happen to know memory of my first love?
Memory of my first love?
I don't think so.
Who's it by?
No.
Not Project Diva.
Project Sekai.
Because they can't say Sekai Project.
And they can't call the game.
It's Project Sekai, but they can't call it that.
Because there's a company called Sekai Project that...
It's too close to the name.
Hello, I'm Sekai.
What's your name?
Oh my gosh!
Uma Pyoie!
Kingdom Hearts!
Oh my gosh.
Kingdom Hearts song.
But we're not singing...
We're not singing...
You know...
Game song.
We're singing any song.
After three years, I finally have a stable income again.
So I'm changing back from chronic lurker to semi-frequent super chatter.
Oh my gosh.
Father!
Congratulations!
But you can still chat!
You don't have to be a lurker!
You don't have to...
You don't have to dono!
It's okay!
Thank you though!
Congrats!
Madoka OP.
Uh...
The Claris one?
Babycorn thinks in the power of Chiropter!
Do I get Indian or Ramen tonight?
Indian!
Butter Chicken Curry.
Yum, yum.
What's under...
Wa, wa, wa...
Wedding songs.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Amai...
Oh my...
Oh no!
No!
Not Sangatsu Kokona Kanna!
Serval!
Thanks to the vibe gifted.
Really thanks to the vibe gifted!
I do sound a little raspy.
Oh no... I'm okay.
Wait, isn't that the song from...
No game, no life.
What the...
Konomi no one?
I'll be honest.
I don't know No Game No Life very much.
Very thanks to the vibe gifted!
It's been five months.
Chill birthday.
Lil happy birthday!
But...
Hold on.
Let me sing happy birthday and then I'll explain what I want to do.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
To you.
Happy birthday dear Lu.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
So, because I'm just like...
I...
There's so many songs we can sing.
Basically, what I want to do is go to genre.
Hermocrates!
Thanks to the vibe gifted!
And under joy sound...
I'm using the joy sound switch app, in case you're wondering.
They have...
And this is basically...
If you go to anime...
Or...
Anime...
Sorry, I was reading it.
If you go to karaoke in Japan, you can go to genre and there's always an anime genre.
So, you can go to anime.
For real!
And look at this!
Look, they have some that are separated by year.
And then it always starts...
Every time!
It always starts with Ame-gami-sama.
But you know what?
I know...
Ish.
One song.
Ame-gami-sama.
So it's really a song...
From Ame-gami-sama.
It's Ishida Yoko, but it's not...
That one.
Not...
Wait, is this one?!
It's from like...
Not the original, Ame-gohdes?
It's like...
The remake of Ame-gohdes?
Eternal Snow or anything from Full Moon...
I can do!
Oh my gosh.
I've never sung this song before.
Open your mind.
I don't know if I know it though.
Okay, but yeah, so I want to do... what I want to do... wait, did I say that right?
What I want to do is if I can get inspiration in this list, we can just go through it.
There's only 8,653 titles.
So I don't think it'll take too long, you know?
It's no big deal.
It's like so easy, you know?
We can start with the icots.
What do I want to sing though?
I don't know.
Only.
What do you mean only?
Krish, thanks for the five-gifter!
Fifteen years in Steins Gate?
Fif... Fifteen?
Fifteen years...
Should we sing... Should we start with Steins Gate?
Wait, I would have to search it.
I want to go through the list though.
Oh my gosh, it all starts... it's all like...
There's so many things that start with like... so many idol anime.
So it's all just idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol, idol...
Idol, idol, idol...
Stay good!
Thanks for 5 months!
Stein's cape was 2011.
Butterfly!
You know what?
That's a great...
Oh, wait.
I just accidentally pressed...
You know what?
Butterfly is a great one to start with.
I love Butterfly.
You know what?
That's such a good Annie song to start with, right?
That's just like... good... everybody knows Butterfly.
Everybody knows Butterfly!
Sorry.
I'm gonna be a little all over the place today because I...
Oh my gosh, you could just do the Sabikara.
No, we wanna sing... I think I know it well enough to sing the whole one.
Maybe.
I have the
karaoke background!
So it's like really a karaoke!
It's like, not just the visuals, it's so funny!
It's so low!
Oh my gosh, it's a little off.
I just wanna have a break, shall we?
Yeah.
No, I can't.
His voice is allワ 아니라
Wow.
Even with unreliable wings, I'm sure I'll be able to fly.
Oh, my love.
How's the audio?
The chorus sounded so good!
I'll become a floating butterfly and ride on the gentle wind.
I'll go to see you wherever I go.
Even if I say vague things, they're surprisingly useful.
I'm screaming.
I wonder what's going to happen in this city.
But I don't know.
In this world that can't be allowed after an infinite dream,
I'll be the most common sense.
Oh, my love.
I'll go to see you wherever I go.
Even with unreliable wings, I'm sure I'll be able to fly.
Oh, my love.
The karaoke is so funny, isn't it?
The guy is so emo!
It kinda looks like Korsuke.
Oh, my love.
In this world that can't be allowed after an infinite dream,
I'll be the most common sense.
Oh, my love.
Even if I say vague things, they're surprisingly useful.
I'll go to see you wherever I go.
I'll be the most common sense.
Oh, my love.
In this world that can't be allowed after an infinite dream, I'll be the most common sense.
Even if I say vague things, they're surprisingly useful.
I'll be the most common sense.
Isn't the纯 to lose a ride bad enough?
the纯 to lose a ride bad enough?
in this정 I'll fly for sure.
Oh, my love.
That was
such a good one to start with!
Are you singing through OBS?
Yes, actually.
It's a little... I'm trying to follow along, but I'm having to listen more than read.
I have to read the lyrics, but I can't follow how it tracks over the words.
So it's a little delayed!
But I can listen!
It's okay!
Wait, do I sound delayed?
I shouldn't, right?
I shouldn't because the audio is tracking through my interface.
No, it's good?
Okay, good.
This is where I put my device.
Stop.
Oh, Matara.
Oh, Matara!
Right on time?
Okay, good.
I was gonna say.
Even though I'm through OBS, it should be okay.
It should be okay and... oops, my bad.
And we have the karaoke background!
Oh my gosh, I'm so glad I discovered that earlier.
I was just like, this is so funny.
This is so funny.
Let's see.
What's like a 2019 song?
Something... kind of a little bit nostalgic.
Oh, Pretender!
Wait, this is Annie's song?
Confidence Man?
What the hell is this?
This is the one that Kiwawa sung.
I really like this one.
I don't know if I remember it so much though.
What app is this?
It's called JoySound.
It's on the Switch.
Zombie Land song.
We'll get there.
Oh my gosh!
Bokken desho!
Okay, Lia.
For you, I'll sing Bokken desho.
I'll sing Suzumiya Haruhi.
Hi, Lia!
Haruhi.
Bokken desho desho.
I'm literally in love with you.
Stop!
That's me at you.
Hahaha.
Bokken...
Is that?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
We'll do maybe a couple Haruhi songs or something.
Okay, hold on.
Let me update.
I'll try and update the... now playing.
Bokken desho.
Desho... desho.
I'll try to update it.
I didn't put a setlist because...
I already have so much of the screen taken up by the karaoke thing, so...
Sorry.
Should do a little tick tick tick.
Right?
Whoa, wait, wait.
The answer is always in my heart.
Where's the Purigara?
Where is the Purigara?
Here we go!
Okay, here we go.
Here we go again.
Anato o eranda watashi desu.
Mou tomaranai unmeisama kara kimerane kai kedo.
I believe...
Mane dake ja tsumaranai no.
Thank you for watching.
Please subscribe to our channel and give us a thumbs up.
Thank you very much.
But yeah, sorry, my Japanese is subpar.
I like, so I can understand better than I can speak.
And, you know, so like when I hang out with like Ayami-sensei and stuff, it's her talking a lot and I'll just be like...
And I'm very bad...
This is why I'll never be like a translator or something because I'm so bad.
I can barely speak and come up with words in English.
So when we went to Disney together, it was me, Matara and Ayami-sensei.
And Ayami-sensei would say something and she'd be like, she'd be like, can you please translate it for Matara?
And I'd be sitting there like, how do I translate that word?
I'd be like...
And at one point, she was just like, Ayami-sensei was like, do you know Japanese?
And I was like, no.
I was like, I'm a pretender.
Fake it till you make it, baby.
So, you know.
You know, there's troubles again.
I do not perceive.
I want to try Pretender.
Is it okay?
I don't remember it so well, I think.
I can stop at mid-song if I'm just like, you know what?
I'll learn this for next karaoke.
I don't remember it.
Sorry.
What else happened?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, Koi Suit and Fortune Cookie.
This is not any song.
This is not anime.
But it's under 2019, I guess.
Oh my gosh, Dragon Ball Kai.
Wait.
Yes?
I don't know.
Wait.
Wait, why is it like...
These are not any song.
This is just 2019 songs.
Okay, never mind.
We're not going to use this list.
It's misleading.
It's very misleading.
Any song is kind of misleading.
It's kind of vague label.
Yeah, okay.
I get what you mean.
Because like in Japan, they'll throw like...
If you go through this list, you'll see...
Like, look!
The Peanuts movie!
I love Snoopy.
Anything that's animation just kind of gets thrown into this, right?
Oh my gosh, the Iris movie.
What's...
I saw this movie.
The Iris movie?
It's very cute.
It's very funny.
It's like...
It feels like very for kids.
But I don't remember I For You.
What other Iris...
Or...
I know there's probably a ton of Iris in here.
Let's see.
Oh gosh.
I probably should...
Okay, I kind of went through this list a little bit earlier.
I didn't...
I think I barely got through the As though.
Oh my gosh.
Aki-Kan.
Wow.
But that's...
Akiba's Trip.
I don't know any songs from Akiba's Trip though.
What's in here?
What?
Haruna Luna?
This is my favorite anime song.
Lips of an Angel.
With the lips of an angel.
Akiba's Beat.
Claris?
What?
I do not want to remember Aki-Kan existed.
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot AOP did the song for...
Milky Holmes?
And yeah, I remember ear horns.
Milky...
Wait, where is...
When is a Milky Holmes in...
What?
Oh my gosh.
And they have like such random stuff on here too.
Like...
Awkwars...
Awkwars.
Awkwars 6 Live.
Windy Stage.
Hmm...
Aquarium?
There was some stuff in here that I thought was really cool.
Hold on.
Like I said, I went through it a little bit earlier.
Oh my gosh!
It's Salt Lily!
I don't know any songs but...
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
Any 90s anime.
Yeah!
Usse...
Ussewa.
Oh gosh, I don't know if I can sing that song well though.
Usse...
Ussewa.
Konyaba Hurricane.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh.
I have not heard that song in so long.
Voitan!
I don't know if I'll be able to sing it though.
Azumanga Daiya!
Wait, what's the difference between...
Wait, is this like the OVA?
Like the really...
I remember watching the...
Like the one that looks so beautiful.
Platinum by Maya Sakamoto.
Yes, I know it!
I can sing it later.
I want to do some card capture stuff.
So, that means...
Wait, what's the difference between the animation and this one?
Oh, it's the same.
But you guys remember how like there was like that initial like Azumanga Daiya anime that was like so beautifully animated.
It was so...
So...
It was so good.
And then they came out with the full series.
Yeah, the web anime!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
The 5-minute short.
Yes, yes, yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
I used to watch it over and over and over again.
It was so good.
Satan Dagi!
I'm gonna try...
Wait, Raspberry Heaven.
Raspberry Heaven!
Oh my gosh, it's...
It's been so long since I've sang this.
Or listened to this song even.
Let's try Soramimi Cake.
Akiba's Trip ED has had different Akiba artists.
Like the...
Like illustrations.
I have watched a little bit of Akiba's...
Akiba's Trip, the anime.
But I never finished it.
Oh my gosh, so cute!
Ru,
Ra, Ru, piano no asakai no yume.
Sakku no hara ni melody.
Kowareta tokei wo shinjite.
Jikan wa dare no mikari.
Tata.
Doushite konna no watashi no mune.
Yasashii dareka no mattteru no.
Oshiete suteki na mirai.
Moonlight.
Sleeping.
Ru, Ra, Ru, omoiden.
Ringo ni mezame no shoujo ga.
Kisu shite.
Zetsuna ku hirogeta hon ni wa futari.
No bell ga naru yo.
Dagi, I feel like I can fly.
I feel like I'm in the wrong key.
Oh gosh.
Why are we in space now?
Obvious Quinn strikes again?
Yeah.
I don't know this song at all.
I heard that voice.
Obvious moment.
I'm so sorry.
I don't remember much Interstellar Space Travel and Azumaga now.
This music video, it started with the rabbits and stuff.
What happened?
That was so bizarre.
Cool.
I'm happy that I'm able to sing some songs I don't usually sing.
Oh no, we have to go.
Wait.
Oh no.
Okay, let's just go back to Azumaga Dayo.
Azumaga Dayo, Azumaga Dayo.
Chiyo's dad probably travels through space.
I wish I were a bird.
Azumaga Dayo.
I remember really liking Raspberry Heaven though.
Raspberry Heaven.
Chance we get Kotoko Shooting Star?
Yes.
Wait, hold on.
Let me make a list.
Cardcaptors?
Cardcaptor Sakura.
Shooting Star.
Azumadin?
Madden?
Azumadin.
Azumaga Dayo makes my sides hurt.
Such a good show.
Such a good... wait, did I pass it?
Oh no, no, no.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh, Azure Lane.
Asobi Asobase.
I don't know anything from it though.
There's so many anime that I'll be like, Oh, it's this anime.
I don't know anything from it.
Oh, it's this anime.
I don't remember the song.
I only know the chorus.
Apple TV.
Oh, Dreams.
What about the iPad one?
iPod.
Oh my gosh.
Daft Punk, my favorite anime song.
Hey Mama.
What is this?
Wow.
Appleseed.
Oh, sorry, there's an iPad Nano too.
First.
Another.
Why are the songs in another?
Ally Project.
Okay, does the song start like with...
I like when she sings the songs.
They make me happy when I hear what she makes you go.
Oh, see here, we have Frozen.
Thank you.
Can I sing Frozen?
It's technically Annie's song.
Fairlyn, thanks.
Welcome to Japari Park.
Oh my gosh.
I sang that.
Japari Park.
I sang that actually recently at karaoke.
I can sing it.
Yeah.
Both.
Sugoi and Tanoshii.
I'll sing it in Japanese.
Okay.
Please find a song to keep with the theme.
Okay, guys?
I don't know if I've ever sang it.
Let it go.
She's so emo.
Is she crying?
No, don't cry.
Oh my God.
降り始めた雪は足跡を消して 真白な世界に一人の私 風が心に囁くの このままじゃダメなんだと
戸惑い 傷つき 誰にも打ちかけずに 悩んでた それも やめよう
ありのままの姿見せるのよ ありのままの姿見せるのよ
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
Oh my gosh!
Is this a love song?
Why is she breaking up with him?
What's going on?
She's letting it go.
You guys.
She let it go.
So dramatic.
Oh my gosh.
What anime was that from?
That was from Fudozen.
Let it ghost?
Let it ghost.
Oh no.
We're going to have to go through the whole list again.
This is kind of...
I have some songs.
Actually, I have some songs I want to sing.
So we'll go back through the list in a bit.
For now, let's go do some of the songs that...
Like, let's see.
Is it like...
Wait, am I stupid?
I think I'm dumb.
Hold on.
Wait, what am I thinking of?
Ka...
It's Kado.
Yeah.
What am I thinking of?
Sometimes they like stylize things, you know?
Kado Kaptur.
Kaptur.
K-K-K-K-Kaptur.
Kado Kaptur.
I don't know.
I need to...
Nanai no Biori.
No, no.
Oh, I don't know.
Biori OP.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
What?
Joy!
Looking for the Hawkeye Super!
Oh, oh, wait.
I need a...
I need a small.
How do I make it small?
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss.
Wait, hold...
No, no, no!
I messed up.
My bad.
Hold on.
Wait.
Oh, X.
X.
How do I make it small?
Wait.
Oh, I see...
If I do this...
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Okay.
It's been a while since I've used this.
Sorry.
There we go.
Okay.
Kaido Kyapta.
There's so many I want to do here.
I'll start with this one.
This one's so nostalgic for me.
Fukushiki no Karte?
I would, but I think my stream will get taken down.
It's good for our vest, but still...
Yeah.
It's getting me excited!
Oh, this girl likes to dream.
How do I get anything done right?
You're really good at favouritism.
I have an idea, but I feel that Mar Master bleed...
Wow!
California, maybe!
Thank you for watching this video.
If you like this video, please subscribe to my channel.
See you in the next video.
Bye-bye.
Thank you for watching this video.
See you in the next video.
Bye-bye.
Thank you for watching this video.
See you in the next video.
Bye-bye.
Thank you for watching this video.
See you in the next video.
Bye-bye.
Thank you for watching this video.
See you in the next video.
What?
What are you... What?
What are you talking about?
What if for the next karaoke stream you gave members the code to add songs to your playlist?
How do I do that?
You can do that?
With Joysop?
Why is the Carpenters in the top ranking?
Interesting.
Oemo did it before?
Really?
Hi Minto, do you know any songs by Hokutsuwa?
What's that?
Sakura Kiss from Oran!
Wait, hold on.
What do you mean, Godder?
What does that mean?
Let me karaoke pause.
Thanks!
What is that?
Wait, what is it?
What is it?
What did I say?
What did I just... what?
Hokutsuwa girl?
Wait, I probably shouldn't say it.
It's a TikTok thing.
What?
Oh wait, I think I know.
I think I know what you're talking about.
The girl that was just like... did that interview, right?
The street interview thing?
I just sang Wholesome Cardcaptor Sakura.
And you're gonna come in here... wait... and you're gonna... you're gonna... you're gonna ruin the vibe.
Bad chat.
I'm vibing.
This is the last Sakura song I'll do.
There is one Tsubasa song I want to see if they have.
Oh yeah!
Look at this guy!
Holy reverb scares me.
He is a dreamer Hisomu power
Watashi no sekai Yume to koi to fuan de dekiteru
It's so romantic!
Like how someone said cringe music video that's just that's just karaoke music videos That's why they're the first.
What is he doing?
He is a dream.
I didn't expect the cut.
He's so blue power.
I'm sorry!
Oh my god, this is so good.
Stop, I'm reading chat.
Stop saying staring contest.
They're not even getting wet.
I'm so sorry that I could not I could not stop the music video.
I'm so sorry.
I could not stop laughing.
Oh, that was Platinum.
Sorry, I forgot to update the list.
That was Platinum from Cardcaptor Sakura.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
That was so funny though.
That was so funny!
Shiny days.
Okay.
I want to try the orange.
There's... wait.
Oh, the Tsubasa.
Let me try Tsubasa real quick.
And then I'll go to ORA in high school, high school.
Trying to sing songs that I don't usually sing, right?
Oh my gosh.
I almost called you the wrong name.
Preparations for throwing off the vibe.
Stop.
Also requesting Hana Yamada opening.
Okay.
Hana, thank you for talking so far.
Please put the Tsubasa towards the video.
Stop.
Thank you.
Tsubasa.
Not... stop.
Tori no uta.
I can sing.
Do I just put in Kuronikuru?
Okay, I'll invest.
I'll invest.
Let's see.
There's a lot of the songs I don't remember.
But there... oh, this one.
Oh my gosh.
I really... okay.
This song is sad song.
Okay, guys.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even press it.
It did it for me.
That's crazy.
Girls in Pants are... oh my gosh.
Korin, I'm so sorry.
I don't know.
Who you cut this music video for?
雨に濡れた頬は
涙の匂いがした 優しい眼差しの 旅人
静かに響いてる 懐かしい音楽
思い出せない記憶 A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
Oh my gosh, I've never sung that song ever, ever, ever, ever, like not even even once in karaoke before.
I can't believe I remember almost the whole thing.
I can't believe it.
What's the... what's the Japanese title for Oran hosu...
Oran koko shisei?
Oran koko hosutobu?
Oh, really?
That's it?
I kind of want to sing this real quick, sorry.
Sorry.
Odamajo Carnival.
Dokkiri dokkiri don don, fushigi na chikara odorei doshi oda suru.
Bikkuri bikkuri bin bin, nannara nara osu dekinai desho.
Ii yone, kitto mainichi ga michi kiyobi, gakko no naka ni yuuenji.
Yaman shukudai wa senbu komi hako ni sutechae.
Fufufufu.
Kyokasou itemo, kaitenai.
Kedo koneko nigite mo, soupo muku kedo.
Demo ne, moshikashite hontou ni, dekichau kamoshirenai yo.
Ookina koe de bebi fiorita ra, hasari de sawa de utaecha e.
Papa, mama, sentei, kamegami, ojisan, urusai nante de kazan de kan.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Hibike pikara pikara, tonde hashite mawatcha e.
Testo de santen, egao de monten, doki doki, waku waku na nu-mu-kyuu
haus.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Wow, this is so awesome!
Rin
rin, nagare mo bushina, katsura hirou, shiyoda suru.
Pachiri panchiri banban, negai goto kanau yo hi.
Ii desho, ii yo ne!
Iito mainichi ga tanjoubi, haisha-san zutto yasumi.
Itai chusha no yawa kara kaimashu, umaroshi cha e.
Sorry.
Sonna murumi sa, kimi wa warau dake.
Koi ni yuukui ite mo, shippo furu dake.
Demo ne, moshikashite hojou dake.
Hontou ni dekichau kamoshirenai yo.
Tatararattata!
Ookina koe de, pikarapitara.
Muzakende, sawagite, odoucha e.
Papa mama senzu, kami kami ojisan.
Tentei kameru naruchisai, osora ni.
Where are we in space?
It's a little happy fight.
Mubu kamikite, ore ni, genji mo yu.
Woi.
Tara, hasai de sawai.
Kami kami ojisan, urusai nante ne.
Kansai mai.
Kansai komi no.
I can't even read, it's so fast.
I better be...
Tara da, tatara la la la la, la la.
La la la.
Ten te ga ten wa ran ten.
Tokido.
I just wanted a song to pick up the mood after the last one.
Yeah!
Ujamajo Carnival!
That music video was awesome.
Na na na na na, la la.
La la na na na, la la.
Na na na na na, na na.
Cutie honey!
Do you know Ultra Relax?
The second opening...
Maybe.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, Chilli X, maybe.
Hold on, Kodocha.
I'll add it to the list.
Oh my gosh.
Mariaholic?
Actually, I wanted to sing something from Mariaholic.
Okay, hold on.
Oran.
I was gonna do Oran now.
Wait, no, no, no.
Oh, I went all the way back.
Wait, no.
No, go back, go back, go back.
There, there.
Oran.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Love Hina.
Oh my gosh.
Yes!
So...
Takizo, thanks for the thumbnail.
I love it.
Oh, and let me add Komugi too since it's Komugi style.
And Popotan.
Serious request.
Wagamama Mirahar.
Okay.
Maybe hold off on some requests because I have a pretty long list.
Okay?
So I'm gonna catch up to it.
Okay.
Maybe hold off on some requests because I have a pretty long list.
And if you write it now, or say something now, I might forget it later, you know?
So...
Sakura Kiss.
Oh gosh.
Wait, now I'm thinking of Love Hina.
Wait...
Sakura Kiss...
Oh!
I remember!
Kiss, Kiss for Love!
I might not remember the whole thing though.
I was thinking of the ending though.
I really loved the Oran High School Host Club ending, you know?
No, not this one again.
Oh, wait, wait, I totally missed that word.
Oh,
wait, wait, I totally missed that word.
I don't know the full version of this song at all.
Oh, wait, wait, I totally missed that word.
Oh, wait, wait,
I totally missed that word.
Yeah.
That one was tough.
Not gonna lie, that one was tough.
That one was kind of tough.
I tried though.
I tried, I tried, I tried.
It's time... for...
go... to...
go...
Yay!
I have some macross I want to do later.
No worries.
Oh my gosh.
How does the Excel world opening?
Is this the opening?
I can't remember how it goes.
I don't remember.
Oh, there's some Miku songs on here.
I wonder if I should...
There's one!
There's a Vocaloid song I want to sing.
Sorry, it's not any song, but you know, kind of.
Can you sing?
I can't even read that.
I can't even read it.
I like how it just says, say you, say you, say you.
Excel world.
When they got twins.
Oh my gosh, they have resublimity!
I tried singing it before though.
Someone asked for shooting star.
Even though I sang it before, I really love this song.
I love it.
Mahoromatic.
I've only seen the spring special of Mahoromatic.
Not the...
Not the original.
The VOD got pulled.
Okay, let's sing it again.
🎵 🎵 🎵 🎵
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
She's the last woman on earth.
Go!
Na!
Onegai teacher!
Yes!
This song is perfect.
Such a good song!
Sorry if my timing was off on that one.
It was hard to... with the lag, the OBS lag.
Ima mo mukashimo Kotoko saikou yo!
Souda yone!
Kotoko saikou!
I love Kotoko.
Wait, actually, can I go into my history?
And like, just search her again?
Maybe I want to do another Kotoko.
Can I...
Wait, I can put her in my...
In my artist I like.
Hi, it's me!
I meant to sing that one song.
My cat has been staring at the screen Watching this whole karaoke.
Safe to say, myth karaoke is cat approved.
Also, let me get some of those stocks.
Shush!
Motake sailor fuku!
It's too fast!
There is... actually, hold on.
There is another Suzumiya Haruhi song that I want to do, though.
I did Boken desho desho earlier.
But it's another song.
Oh, it's...
Shuuu...
Shuu...
Shuzo...
Shuzumiya...
You know what?
Why not do both?
Oh my gosh, I don't think I've ever sung this song in karaoke before.
This is from Haruhi Suzumiya.
No, no, no, is this music video?
Haruhi Suzumiya!
I will ignore.
I say,
I say, my heaven.
Oh my gosh, I can't read.
I can't
read.
I can't read.
I don't know.
So much kanji.
I can't even read it.
And then these two bozos in the background.
I can't...
It's so much kanji.
I can't even read it.
And then these two bozos in the background.
I can't...
It's so much kanji.
I can't even read.
And then these two bozos in the background.
I can't read.
Why was I mad?
Oh my god.
I still have no idea.
What's going on?
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
I can't even read.
Sorry, I'm trying to read today.
Sorry, but I can't.
Maybe I should like, pull up.
Maybe I shouldn't.
Okay, I'm going to start pulling up lyrics instead of on the...
Instead of going through OBS, it's just been leading to my downfall.
Let me go back to Suzumiya Haruhi, because I do want to sing last in my music.
I do want to sing it!
Groovin' Magic.
I'll think about it, since I did a couple Cardcaptor songs.
That's the one that's...
That one, right?
Okay.
That's my music!
That one.
I still, I still, I love you.
I'm waiting, waiting forever.
I can't stop.
A little pause... and we are back.
約束ふわりと暗い夜に消えた
大好きな人よいつもいつまでも探してしまう きっと目が覚めてもまだ幻を感じたいのに I lost, I lost, I lost you.
You're making, making my music.
I lost, I lost, I lost you.
I can't see you anymore.
No!
For how happy the song is, the lyrics are kind of sad, you know?
The person I love is too far away and I want to cry.
When I wake up tomorrow, you see, hope may be born.
Good night.
The person I love is too far away and I want to cry.
Even if I wake up, I still want to feel the illusion.
You're making, making my music.
I still, I still, I love you.
I'm waiting, waiting forever.
It won't stop.
I still, I still, I love you.
I'm waiting, waiting forever.
We'll meet again, right?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Crawling on my little feet, Bakemonogatari ending.
Didn't you just finish the series?
It's still...
It's still summer, technically.
technically summer.
Oh my gosh.
Have you guys ever...
If you fly to Haneda Airport, if you are leaving from Haneda Airport, get there early.
Right?
Get there early.
Because...
At Haneda Airport in Japan, there is a cafe that I've been wanting to go to for so many years.
And my flight ended up being delayed.
And it was delayed before I went through security.
It's before you go through security.
So you have...
You can actually just go if you want to.
But there is a planetarium.
Oh my gosh.
There's a planetarium cafe.
And...
Oh my gosh.
It was so great.
And it really like just brought my summer to an end.
It was so good.
It was because they had like...
They did like different showings.
You could stay there the whole day if you wanted to.
They were just like, Here's the schedule of things.
And I ended it on this...
Oh my gosh.
On a romantic...
On a romantic viewing of the summer sky.
And it sounded like it was narrated.
It didn't say the narrator.
Though it did say the narrator for like another one.
And it was some dude.
But it didn't say it for this one.
But it sounded like...
Oh my gosh.
It sounded like Saori Hayami.
And I was just like...
It was so soft.
And she was so...
I was like...
Oh my gosh.
It was so nice.
And like...
She was just like...
There's Deneb.
There's...
And it was...
And the whole time I was just thinking of the...
Summer triangle from this song.
Kimi no Shiranai Monogatari.
Prince of Denmark.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
And I was like...
Oh my gosh.
So...
But...
Okay.
It was kind of funny.
Because they advertised it.
It's a cafe.
Right?
They're just like...
Eat while under the stars.
Have a...
Have a snack.
Have a meal.
Under the stars.
No.
If you go...
First of all...
It was like...
It was like a bunch of...
It was like a bunch of girls.
There was not a single couple in sight.
It was so funny.
I thought it was going to be full of couples and then me all by myself.
No.
It was just a bunch of girls.
It was great.
But...
I...
I would like...
I got spaghetti.
And I was eating it.
And I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I guess I'll wait for the show to start.
Because like...
There was no stars while I was eating.
You have to...
You can only go into the...
To the cafe too.
Like during the intermissions.
Um...
And I was like...
Okay.
Well...
I'll...
I'll like...
You know...
Have my meal and my drink while the stars are shining.
And it's like really awesome.
No.
As...
Everyone was eating and drinking.
And then as soon as the show started...
Everybody stopped.
And I was like...
Oh.
Okay.
I'll also stop.
And...
Um...
This is...
My...
And then...
These shows are like 15 minutes long.
And so...
By the time it was over...
My spaghetti was cold.
I actually have a cover of this song.
Did you guys know that?
Maybe you can see if I've gotten better at singing since I've recorded the song.
You can listen to the cover and then listen to this and maybe see if I've I don't know if I've gotten better or if I've regressed.
Oh wait, hold on.
Ah, here!
泣かないで
そう言い聞かせた 泣かないで 泣かないで 強がる私を臆病で 興味がないよなふりをしてた だけど
胸あさす痛みは増したく 胸あさす痛みは増したく 発想化する
I can never remember the mix here.
君の隣がいい 真実は残酷だ
言わなかった 言えなかった
二度と戻れない あの夏の日
Thank you for watching this video.
Every time I sing that song, Every time I sing that song, I'm like, transported back to my...
To like...
Whenever, you know, when you have like a crush on someone but they don't like you back.
Thank you for singing.
It's like, oh, you're my life now, Barry!
Shut up.
It always takes me back to when I had like an unrequited love.
I'm just so sad.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
So, Violet...
Seriously, I only know one song from Violet Evergarden.
Definitely improved.
I'll sing it though.
I'll sing the song from...
Violet Evergarden that I know.
Sorry, it's not this song.
I have so many songs, you guys.
I'm gonna be here forever.
Angel Beat, I have it on the list.
It's sung by True.
It's probably so many songs though.
Thank you, thank you.
Chill!
No, it's True, not Chill.
Going to karaoke later?
Thanks for the cello.
Wait, did I pass it?
Do they not have it?
Did I pass it?
Sorry, I saw 46.
I was like...
Well, maybe they don't have it.
The pillows.
145 bpm catch.
Okay, anyway.
Kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss.
Let's do Japari Park.
I had that on the list forever ago.
Wait, is it...
Is it in Kana?
Ja?
Wait.
I wanted to do Shinjidai.
Can I?
Okay, I'll do Japari Park after this.
Sorry.
I wanted to try it.
I don't think I've ever sung this one before.
Shinjidai is in Boomer?
Shut up!
We're doing a mix!
Little Busters.
Oh my god.
Shinjidai wa kono mirai da Sekai ju zenbu Kaete shimaeba Kaete shimaeba
Morphose shidouse music Kimi ga okosoku Magic Magic Me wo tojireba mirai ga hiraite Itsuwa demo owari ga kono yami ni itte Kono yuta wo uttao yo Do you wanna play?
Real game?
Girigiri?
Tsunawatari mitai na senmitsu Mitomenai?
Modorenai?
Wasurenai?
Yume no naka?
Dai sasete I wanna be free Mieru yo Shinjidai ga Sekai no mukou e Saiku yo new world Shinjidai wa kono mirai da Sekai ju zenbu Kaete shimaeba Kaete shimaeba Hateshinai ongaku ga motto todoku you ni Yume wa mirai wa Kimi ga anashita Boku wo shinjite Oh,
vocalist!
To the rock part!
What is this music video?!
Wow!
This is awesome!
New world!
I want to believe in this future If I change everything in the world If I change it So that endless music can reach more people I'll show you my dream I'll show you my dream It's a new era!
I can't believe it!
I did my best.
Wow, this music video is awesome.
Bring back the night!
Let him be part of every music video!
Why didn't they choose this first song about pirates?
Or forever, you know?
That was good.
That was fun.
That was a good music video.
Yeah, yeah, job.
Job party.
I die, thank you forever.
Such a good song.
Wait.
What app is this?
It's called JoySound.
It's on the Switch.
It's technically free, but you do need a script.
You have to buy like...
Let's do the Japanese app store.
Yokoso!
Wait, but it should still show up with Japari.
Maybe they don't have it.
Yeah, let me try the Yokoso.
Yokoso, welcome to Japan!
Japan-e-pack!
Some wrong notes.
Everybody's a critic.
Sorry if I don't know a song completely well.
It's a minto edition, okay?
Yokoo...
They do have it!
Why didn't it show up when I did?
Did I put a Japan-e-pack wrong?
Whatever.
Wait, there's the parts in this that are just like...
That have like the talking.
It's okay, we'll do it.
Oh wait, hold on.
Welcome to the Japanese Park!
We're back, we're back, we're back!
A big commotion!
Low battery?
Oh no!
Go!
If you laugh at me, I'll be your friend.
Friend!
Even if we fight, we're still friends.
Even if there's a beast, there's no beast.
Even if there's a monster, there's no monster.
The true love is right here.
Come on, you too.
Let's hold hands and go on a big adventure!
Welcome to the Japanese Park!
We're back, we're back, we're back!
A big commotion!
We're 12 different shapes and shapes.
That's why we're attracted to each other.
If you gently put your fingers on the night sky, we can start.
We can start!
Turn!
I want to know more.
If you turn around, over there, over here.
Trouble!
No matter what it is, it's all over the newspaper.
Congratulations on the beast.
Everyone is living freely.
That's right.
You don't have to decorate yourself.
It's okay.
Here you go.
Thank you!
Always, always, always, always
until the morning.
But...
I want to keep
going.
Something, something.
It's fun.
Amazing.
Ah, ah, ah.
I'll go.
Ah, hururu.
Someday, someday else.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh, let's go to the west.
Let's go to the west.
Yay!
Oh, we go up to the Japanesewow!
La, la, la, la...
Let's be friends.
La, la, la, la...!
Welcome to the Japanesewow!
Japanesewow!
I got caught in the crossfires of wanting to do the calls and needing to sing the song.
Yay!
That was Japari Park!
There's another song I want to sing, actually.
I think... I hope that they have backing vocals for this.
If they don't, it will be a tough song.
But I've always loved this song.
Love this song so much!
Can you guys guess from just putting in this?
I wonder...
Oh?
Ringo!
Makire!
Beeeeeeam!
My soul is healed.
It's from Sayonara Zetsubou-sensei.
Sayonara Zetsubou-sensei Sayonara
Zetsubou -sensei Sayonara Zetsubou-sensei
You're like that Tabii tomato beside It's sure Shangri-la I'm with you.
She was beautiful.
Goodbye.icy I'm not!
Sometimes,
people have to beари It's got to be the pers coaches.
I want to do a duet with that song so bad one day.
Let's change the vibes a little bit.
Actually... actually... oh gosh, what was that song called?
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I have to look it up.
Hold on, hold on.
Someone mentioned Maria Halleck earlier.
Now this is a cover... well, rather the song ending is a cover.
But...
What is this?
But we'll do the YMO version.
I think I might have to pitch it up though.
Actually, I kind of want to... do they have the... do they have...
Do they have the Maria Halleck version?
I wonder.
This is it.
Maria Halleck version.
It's a little bit faster, so it's like...
A little more energetic.
Oh, wait.
Because it's pretty different.
I don't think I've ever sung the Maria Halleck version.
Only just the...
YMO isn't Boomer?
What?
Huh?
I think that's the most Boomer you can get.
I love this cover so much though.
It's so cute.
My heart is beating for you.
Kyun!
My story.
I'm holding my hand.
My heart is beating for you.
Kyun!
It's so scary.
I'm being read.
A rumbling line dance.
Just breaking time.
The voltage in my eyes.
While it's burning up.
I have a heart for you.
Kyun!
The cherry blossoms in summer.
Just the sun.
A little pause... and we are back.
The
original is so good, too, though.
But I like the instrumentals in this one.
That was...
You should watch the original music video if you've never seen it.
The YMO version.
Because it's so funny.
The guys are so cute.
They do, like, this cute pose.
You couldn't tell.
If I was in 3D, you'd be able to see me do the CUNE pose that they do in the music video.
I do it every time.
CUNE, CUNE, CUNE!
So cute!
Next song, I want to sing.
But I don't know how to find it.
I wonder if I can find it.
I should find a chord also for my controller that's dying.
One Night Carnival!
I want to sing Kishidan!
I want to sing it!
It should be on here, I feel.
Because...
It's a popular Vocaloid song.
One Night Carnival!
But today...
Well, this isn't technically Ani's song either.
I keep showing up.
I guess this song isn't technically Ani's song either, but...
Whatever.
Vocaloid!
It's kind of, you know?
Whatever.
One Night Carnival!
Isn't
that it?
I love this song!
A counterpoint.
A counterpoint to my song.
It's great.
First, we have this.
It's really good.
Where did this song come from?
It's called Gimmick!
It's an android song.
A little pause... and we are back.
This music video is crazy.
They were like, robot?
Sure.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Let's do another love song.
Someone requested this earlier.
It's technically anime.
It's kind of anime.
It's anime.
It's Annie's song.
It's Annie's song!
Hold
on.
Set list.
You don't say.
I don't know what you meant by that.
I love it.
Ohterm funded?
Yeah.
Sunny, be in love with you.
I've
already decided the number of eights.
Tomorrow's dream will come to life.
I want to you.
Forever.
Surely.
Your
gentle feelings are full.
The first kiss.
With you.
I will give you all my love.
The tears will fall.
Really, in this habit.
Sunny, be in love with you.
This is like the one time it's a song about love.
And they choose outer space.
I'm so confused.
The first kiss.
With you.
I will give you all my love.
For some reason.
Your gentle feelings are full.
The first kiss.
With you.
I will give you all my love.
For some reason.
The tears will fall.
Really, in this habit.
You will just fall in love with you.
With you.
And still won't stop.
Forever.
Seriously.
Really, in this habit.
Totally.
And you cannot think that someone else in this world can be as sweet and sweet as you are.
My time.
I will only be lovin' you too and too, you know.ári
no claro Lovin' you?
Say this to my cats.
Yay!
That was Hajimete na chu!
Okay, since they chose space for this, I must see what they choose.
I believe love can bloom on the battlefield.
On the space battlefield.
Someone requested this one earlier.
It's been a long time since I've sung this one.
The vibe is a little different, but it's also a love song.
Kind of.
Which one?
We'll do this one.
We'll see what they choose for the background of this.
If it's not space, I'm gonna riot.
Do you remember me?
Excuse me, Regina.
Macross.
It must be space.
Space!
What?!
My disappointment is inevitable.
yours are ruined Right now,
I can hear your voice.
Please come back here.
I'm in a sense of loss.
I can see your figure.
You are walking towards me.
My eyes will close.
閉じて待っているわたしに
昨日まで涙で曇ってた 心は今
A little pause... and we are back.
I'm surprised there's no chorus for this one, too.
Maybe I should try a different version.
I wish I had so much better with the chorus in the background.
for instance deserves a new year.
No more open source.
Oh, we're dancing along!
Yeah!
世界は今
覚えていますか 目と目が合った時も
覚えていますか 手と手が触れ合った時 This is the first time we are going on a journey of love.
I love you so.
Because I'm not alone anymore.
Do you remember?
The time when our eyes met.
The time when our hands touched.
This was the first time we were going on a journey of love.
I love you so.
Because I'm not alone anymore.
Because you are here.
This
is the first time we are going on a journey of love.
They cut off the end.
What the heck?
They were like, no 7-minute song for you.
I'm going through the list of songs that people requested.
I wonder
if I can put it under here.
That's a little short one.
Wait, this is a different person though.
It's called Akumi.
Thank you!
First time hearing you sing?
I wasn't familiar with your game.
What is this?
It's called the suger song.
I never heard this before.
I actually don't...
I only know the course of it.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, wait.
Will this work?
I don't know...
I don't know what this version is like.
I want to do the original.
Okay, let's do the...
Let's do the...
Kyu kyu kyu...
Kyu kyu...
Te te te....
Te te..
wait, sorry, te te...
Cutee!
It's little...
Cutie honey!
Cutie Honey!
Kodakumi!
This is the one I want to sing.
Have I ever sung this song before on stream?
Space!
What are you doing?
Please, please, don't hurt me.
My heart is pounding.
I don't want to, I don't want to, I don't want to look at you.
Honey Flash!
Please, please, don't hurt me.
Please, please, don't come any closer.
My heart is pounding.
I don't want to, I don't want to, I don't want to look at you.
Honey Flash!
What's up?
Please,
please, don't hurt me.
Because...
Please, please, don't come any closer.
My heart is pounding.
I don't want to, I don't want to, I don't want to look at you.
Honey Flash!
Oh, I completely forgot the ending!
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh, what did she say at the end?
Um...
I forgot what the...
Oh, fumbled completely.
I'm going to die.
I completely fumbled the ending.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Yay!
Cutie Honey!
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right.
All right, all right.
What other songs?
I have so many more.
How many songs?
How long?
Two and a half hours?
Okay.
Let's do...
The book.
We're in a...
We're on a love streak, clearly.
He...
Nah.
Literally, my childhood is Love Hina.
I watched Love Hina.
I read Love Hina.
Everything in my childhood was Love Hina.
But I...
I grew up...
Everything...
So bad.
It's Love Hina.
Love Hina.
Wait.
Tamara Yukari...
Who did she voice?
That was the Mint Wrestle Cutie Honey ending.
That explains a lot.
What are you talking about?
Oh.
There's so many songs.
Sakura-Saku?
What was the ending?
Winter Wish?
I don't know what to wish!
Sakura Sakuya is the opening, but...
Wait!
There's a song I want to sing!
Okay, I'll do this.
Hold on, let me write it down so I don't forget.
There's a reason I want to sing it too.
Hayashibara Megumi!
Who was she?
Of course, Ho-chan does so many songs because she was Naru.
You get the burning?
I have no disco on the list.
Love Hina was the first manga I read front to back.
I loved Love Hina.
I loved A.I.
Love You.
I loved...
The Christmas one.
I didn't actually read so much of Negima, but...
Akamatsu Ken kind of raised me.
Actually...
Happy Material!
Oh yes, I'll do Happy Material.
Wait, I sang Happy Material earlier.
Or like, recently.
I don't know.
Friendship is such a cute song, but it's like kind of...
And Smile Smile...
Oh my gosh, I think I might cry if I hear this song.
Oh, 2001 version!
Oh my gosh, I might cry.
Yakusoku!
How does it start?
Wait, no, I don't think so.
Is this Yakusoku?
I love my otaku palment.
Thanks to Kao!
Okay, I'll try the opening.
I'll try the opening, even though it's kind of insane.
Sakuu, not the first sakura song we sang today.
Oh, wait.
Sakuu...
I can't believe Hayashibana Megumi did this song.
That's crazy.
What?
Oh gosh, I already feel like I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna be able to sing this at all.
She was Haruka, the cousin who ran...
Oh!
On the roof The sky is red The sun is shining I look up at the sky My body is full of energy I'm overflowing with energy That's so wonderful I'm alive I can't stop I can't give up Why?
Goodbye to yesterday I gave you so long ago This feeling is rising up I'll revive it again and again I'll revive it again and again Let me bloom flowers Memories are always a sweet place to run away Memories are always a sweet place to run away To live tomorrow The time of blessing is coming Stretch out your hand Creepy girl.
What is this killer child?
The soft and soft skin of the softness I still close my hands Oh my gosh.
If I close my eyes, the image blooms The fruit of the charm That's so wonderful I'm alive I can't stop I want to see the future Haha The days of the earth continue No matter where I go Heaven and hell I'll never go back I'll revive it again and again Let me bloom flowers Run,
run, until I find love If you suffer with that The place you wish for The time of blessing is coming Stretch out your hand A little
pause...
and we will吧 I'm shocked we're still getting new videos I'm shocked we're still getting new videos Why are we at the grass now?
What's going on?
And I still love Loving Hina I still love Loving Hina I still love Loving Hina Get up A kiss A touch A kiss A touch
A kiss
Yeah, I love NaRu the most.
How'd you know?
Creepy little girl, creepy little girl.
It's nostalgic, isn't it?
Natsukashii!
Oh my god, oh my god.
She's touching grass, for real.
Let's go, little girl!
Okay, let's do some more nostalgic songs.
This is four.
Wait, didn't I?
Oh!
I wanted to do this song.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I changed my mind.
This one is...
I think actually this one is kind of...
also nostalgic.
It's nostalgic for me.
And it's also composed by one of my favorite composers ever.
So...
And also, the reason I want to sing it is because it was trending earlier because the manga is currently free.
Wait.
I love this song too, though.
Wait, I'm thinking of a different song.
Nevermind.
Maybe, wait.
Hold on.
Um...
I...
There's another song.
It's on the same single as...
Furendo Shitai, but I can't remember what the B-side is.
Anyways, it's Gakkou Gurashi!
You guys remember this song?
What was the...
I can't remember how this opening goes.
I only actually...
Maybe I only remember the lyrics or the chorus.
Uh-oh, maybe I should've...
I love this song.
Or I love this show.
Ah, here we go.
If you want to do it, if you want to do it, you want to do it when you want to, right?
Together, yes!
We are here.
There is a dream here.
If you're a friend, you're a friend, right?
That's right!
How
do I say it?
Oh, wait.
How does the full version go?
That's right!
Zombie!
Everybody's a zombie!
Yay!
Furen shitai!
From Gakkou Gurashi!
The other song on the B-side of that is so cute too.
Ta-da!
I wonder if I can search it through.
Just searching komugi.
Someone asked for me to sing the Kom Su Su Tod song.
Maybe I should do that.
Isn't this technically any song?
It counts!
It's like the one English song we'll sing today.
Kom Su Su Tod.
Su Su harmonica man Play it!
Play that harmonica!
I want to hear it!
Tod!
Play it!
My favorite song.
Go!
Ya!
Here we go!
Maybe I should have I don't even know how many songs I've sung!
Are you guys having fun?
Are you guys liking the karaoke a little bit?
I hope so.
I hope I sound alright today.
I know, I know I've let you down I've been a fool to myself I thought that I couldn't live for no one else But now, through all the hurt and pain It's time for me to respect The ones you love mean more than anything So with sadness in my heart I feel the best thing I could do Is end it all and leave forever What's done is done It feels so bad What's once was happy now is sad I'll never love again My world is ending I wish that I could turn back time Cause now the guilt is all mine Can't live without the trust from those you love I know we can't forget
Broadway?
I wish that I could turn back time.
Cause now the guilt is all mine.
Can't live without the trust from those you love.
I know we can't forget the past.
You can't forget love and pride.
Because of that it's kill... killing me inside.
It's killing me.
Where's like... where are my backup singers at?
Where are my backup singers at?
It all returns to nothing.
It just keeps tumbling down, tumbling down, tumbling down.
I just keep letting me down, letting me down, letting me down.
It all returns to nothing.
It just keeps tumbling down, tumbling down, tumbling down.
I just keep letting me down, letting me down.
How old do you think this footage is?
We
all return to nothing.
Nice.
Goodbye world!
Uninstall!
Oh my gosh, yes!
Wait, can I put it in?
In English?
Maybe if I search Bokurano, right?
Grateful friends.
I was listening to it during lockdown.
How to look it up was bugging me.
Oh, thank you!
Grateful friends.
What if I put in Bokurano?
Cool.
Isn't that also written in Romaji do Boku?
Oh, wait.
I just realized it probably will give us like a bunch of stuff.
Probably.
Oh, it's there!
Yippee!
Oh gosh, I have to remember.
Test.
This karaoke sounds ancient.
You know how like some karaoke sound more recently made?
This sounds ancient.
Kana
Toke Saiko no Riyaru ga Mukokara wa Ae ni Kitetta no Wa Bokurano Sonzai wa Konnani mo Tanjun da to Warai ni Kita nana
Wait, the timing is really off.
Oh, this girl is so cute!
Yeah, ita!
He framed it!
I can't speak.
Iris!
You have to do it!
Oh wait, I missed my big Q.
Hold on.
I missed my Q.
Okay, I'm... I'm... I'm...
Oh my gosh!
You guys...
Goodbye!
Just kidding.
I still want to sing some more.
Oh my gosh.
I just messed up everything.
I just messed up my entire setup.
No!
What just happened?
I think I'm better.
I became big for a second.
Landscape mode.
Landscape mode!
Okay.
Let's see.
Okay, I did say I was going to sing this earlier and I got distracted.
I will sing it now.
Oh wait, let's actually...
Do it from...
Na...
Su...
Actually, I sang Nurse Switch Kamugi before.
Maybe I should sing Popo-tan this time.
Actually...
Maybe I'll sing a different Nurse Switch Kamugi song if they have one.
Hold on, let's see.
Na...
Su...
U...
Ichi...
Oh!
Let me just search Nurse.
Nice!
Okay, they have that one.
Why did it...
When I...
Oh, maybe because it's the Chisa...
Chisa...
Ui.
It's Ui.
I can't just put the U.
I have to put the Ui.
U...
Ui.
There we go.
You are shocked!
I can't remember all of you.
I only know you are shocked.
So there's I Know Medicine, but I wanna do...
I always sing I Know Medicine, so this time I'm gonna sing an insert song from Nurse Switch Kamugi.
I hate you so much!
We've sang too many songs about love today.
Oh, wait.
I hate you so much.
I can't even remember...
clue I know.
Now I can't that type of thing anymore.
Oh, did you change your way of thinking?
Annoying face, stupid face, bad design commands.
I melted and I settled in all of you...
Iyyy...
duh...
I can't understand...
All of these feelings.
I can't nope.
I'll just make change and make them into good things.
Dist核, guitar!
Miss...
I love you...
James!
Oh,
I should have had this face on the whole time.
This is my... this is my song for...
I hate you!
Sing it again?
Okay.
It's not that long of a song.
One more time, but actually hating you.
One more time, but actually... POV, she really hates you.
And doesn't think that you will become a psycho couple.
I mean...
Oh,
stay away from me, I hate you!
It's not that long of a song.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
This is my... this is my song for...
I hate you!
And this is my... this is my song for...
And doesn't think that you will become a psycho couple.
One more time...
This video is the best one!
So glad we got this one.
I'm so glad we did this song again to get this video.
What is going on?
Oh my god!
I got 10 times more...
Oh my god, the b-ball couple.
These bros cooked.
The b-ball couple.
They are too strong.
B-ball, b-ball, b-ball, b-ball.
Okay, let's see...
So that was my kumugi.
I'll save Popotan for another day since I did kumugi twice in a row.
Yosakoi, yosakoi!
This is from the anime Hanayamada.
Hana wa odore ya irohani ho.
I always struggle with singing this song though.
Oh wait...
Hana wa odore ya irohani ho.
Okay, such a cute anime, I know right?
Yay!
I watched it earlier.
Can you do the dance?
I can!
I actually do know the dance.
I actually do.
For real, for real.
One day in 3D I'll show you.
Monaka!
Oh my gosh, no wonder this song is awesome.
I honestly love this song.
I'll show you.
So what does it say?
It says, This is a new genre where the group is very different.
So I've been thinking about choosing the genre of popular songs.
Kazoetai atarashii keshiki Iroha ni ho pato pato hare yaka ni sakasemashou Hana no you ni kore kara no kimi ga mitai Iroha ni ho pato pato hare yaka ni sakaseru omoi o tsurenareru A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
I don't want to lose you.
I
don't want to lose you.
She went to heaven before us, so...
It brought back a lot of memories.
All of a sudden.
Poro!
Thanks for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
In fact, I'm gonna sing a song for her.
Hold on, I just gotta make sure I get the name right.
I think I remember it, but...
Uh...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I was right.
It should be this one, I think?
I'm actually not so sure about the kanji.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Um...
I...
Don't remember exactly the full version of the song, but...
But we'll do our best.
Tochu, yeah.
Tabi no Tochu.
Oh, this is from Spice and Wolf.
I
wandered alone in my heart I stood up But now I can walk far away But I can walk and walk away Tetsu.
Now we've met in the distance We can be tee at it I've met you When all the thirsty fans sing That never-ending song A song you sing so punishingly A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
I'm stopping because I don't know how to read!
I don't remember that part.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okie-dokie.
Guys, we're coming up.
I should probably... okay.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Okay, I can do 8 more songs.
I'm gonna power through them.
I'm getting kind of tired, so...
Maybe... wait.
Did I count that one?
Maybe not.
Hold on.
I wanna see if I know any Kodocha songs.
Someone...
This was a long time ago.
Someone asked Kodocha.
But I love Kodocha!
Oh my gosh.
Sana is so cute!
Kodocha.
Cha.
I think my battery has been low for like the past hour.
Oh wait, oh wait.
I have to put in Kodomo no Omocha.
Oh, that's what it is.
Kodomo.
Sorry, I'm putting in the anime name.
So the anime is Kodomo.
Kodomo.
But Kodocha is like the short name, you know.
Kodomo no...
No, no...
Omocha...
O...
Mo...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No Jikan.
No!
Shut up!
You had me for like two seconds.
Oh wait, ultra-relax?
That was the one, right?
Oh my gosh, you literally just got me.
I was like, oh, no jikan!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Okay, this might be the only song that I stopped mid-song today.
Because... I'm gonna see, I'm gonna see, I'm gonna see.
Is this the one that's like...
Is that this one?
Okay, now let's listen.
Ah,
what is this music video?
Listen!
But
I'm doing the dance at the same time from the Kodō-chan!
RILAX!
Why are the lyrics cutting off?
Delicious.
Why are the lyrics cutting off sometimes?
What is going on?
You hear that bum bum?
That's the part that it cuts off.
This
is so evil.
What is
happening?
Oba -san, pants!
Why are we talking about...
Why are we talking about Oba-san's pants?
I did my best.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to write.
You know what?
Maybe it's...
Actually, for anybody who was interested in the name of that song, it's called Ultra.
Ultra, relax.
From Kodo-chan.
Kodomo na Oma-chan.
I did my best there.
Hatsune Miku no Shoushitsu.
I'm like 99% positive it's on here.
Now I'm gonna mess up another song.
I'm like paranoid now.
I feel like I need to pull up the...
My controller died!
Uh oh.
Hold on.
Okay.
The Joy-Con still works.
It's alright.
We're all good.
This song, I always... Like, I like this song.
I can never sing it well.
So I never sing it.
But I recently saw this song live at Anisama.
Wagamama Mirahar!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait.
Wagamama Mirahar.
Well, you're right.
Yeah!
Okay.
I can never sing this song well.
I always get, like, parts of it wrong.
But you know what?
It's fine.
Wagamama Mirahar!
Samasana hitomimou miteyo.
Too scary!
Ne, kirei na dake da tsuyogarenai.
Sou, barami mo togega.
Tsukiteru deshou.
Kizutsuite ii yo.
Guande.
Taifu demo nai.
Butsukatte gomashita.
You're a sign.
Please don't.
Please wait.
Sakebitai no ni.
Wagamama Mirahar.
Sakasama ni.
Jujou yurete.
Kimi kara wa urahara ni.
Utsuru no.
Soredemo mireba ha.
Sate yori mo.
Tsurugi na kodoro.
Gara sumi e nikori sensai na no yo.
Wakaru deshou.
Kizuita yo.
Dakara kyousei.
Watashi wo maru goto.
Kizumete hoshii no.
Semu yoyu na furi uke.
E to tte.
Shy boy.
Oh my gosh.
I have to, like, refuse my body.
It's from going...
Body!
Stop!
Sono line kara fumikomanai de.
Why?
Doushite nuru mo morenai no.
Hatsudo shichau.
Ippai wa udodou yo.
Sou yatte gomakasu no wa.
What is this?
Wattehoyan te nozokanai de.
Hohohoyan te iwasanai de.
Please don't, please wait.
Chiba ni asenau no wo.
Satoranai nai de yo.
Wakara na miragou.
Anoha hante sasete.
Shintetsu urahara ni utsushitai.
Oozame na miragou.
Kitai goto fumutte ateru kana.
Sonna ijii ni hodosanai yo.
Shinteru deshou.
Sou yukoto yo.
I'm out of breath.
Shinteru.
Yabeya!
Yowabushi mirror heart.
Itsudatte amonojaku.
Sunao ni warenai nande agenai.
Wagamama mirror heart.
Sakasama ni juujou yurete.
Kimi kara wa urahara ni utsuru no.
Soredemo mirror heart.
Tate yori mo tsurugi na kodoron.
Garasu zaiko yori sensai na no yo.
Wakaru deshou.
Kizuite yo.
Dakara kyousei watashi wo maru hodo.
Mitsumete hoshii no.
Watashi no dokoka wo oikanai de.
Zemu yoyou na furi de wa atasete yo.
Muchiori usou to de.
Tumete saiboi.
Yay!
My attempt at wagamama mirror heart.
Holy moly.
You made it, somehow.
I'm fumbling my way through these songs.
Fumbling my way, I'm fumbling my way.
Fumble fumble fumble.
The next song?
I think many people probably know it.
Oh, oops.
Like I know it, but do I know it to sing it?
Whatever.
It's been a while since I heard that song.
If you go to Anikura, you'll hear wagamama mirror heart all the time.
You will hear it all the time.
But it's been so long since I've been to Anikura.
I forget some of the calls sometimes.
Fumbling down.
'' mythology around music '' '' ''
Rosie '' '' I I ''
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Yes, this is a true otaku song.
Yes,
this is a true otaku song.
Colors might flow.
My otaku heart is flowing with otaku energy.
Super chat!
You distracted me from the outro!
I was too bewildered.
Yay!
I just wanted to sing some kind of song like that.
I feel like everybody knows...
Everybody knows Jibiru-mo se kai saimou.
I'm going to focus now on songs.
I would sing Chinese days, but I feel like I sing it very often.
I'm going to kind of focus on songs that I don't sing very often, so...
I'm sorry if you asked for a song...
and I didn't sing it.
But I kind of want to sing this one too.
I think they have it.
It's the first one.
I hope you guys don't mind.
Let's sing some...
some...
key songs.
Key song, I guess.
This is the only one I have really.
Oh!
I'm so wrong!
Holy shit!
Wait!
I'm so stupid.
Sorry.
I can't read ever.
Why did you guys stop me?
Is it not on here?
I don't think it's on here!
Yeah, the one by Lia!
I didn't even think about it.
I just...
Oh my gosh!
Yeah!
Because I was like, the kanji...
The kanji is correct though, right?
Oh my gosh!
They don't even have it!
Noooo!
Natsukage!
Still technically something.
Actually, I think I remember that about a lot of...
A lot...
A lot of...
Key songs are not on here.
Let's see that.
Yeah, oh yeah...
Yeah, the key songs are not in Joy Sound.
Yeah...
I think I remember that now.
No...
I'm more sorry for you not knowing Girls and Panzer.
No, no!
I know Girls and Panzer!
I know Girls and Panzer, of course.
I just don't know songs.
Hahaha!
I know...
Nanana...
Love Natsukage no...
Dang.
Okay.
Well, that's alright.
It's okay.
That's okay.
We'll do the complete opposite vibe.
Oh wait, I sing this song pretty often I feel like too, but...
It's okay.
It's a classic.
Eternal Snow?
No, Eternal Blaze!
And then we can maybe do Eternal Snow.
I do still have Full Moon on the list, don't worry.
I do still have it.
Okay.
I have a surprise we're still getting new videos, my goodness!
Look at this fashion queen!
Tsumagai Midori no Tsuki ni Utsushidasu Kokoro no Kage Samishike ni Tsuyaita Kimi no Soba ni Itai no Igo
Thank you for watching this video.
If you like this video, please subscribe to my channel.
See you in the next video.
And if you like this video, please subscribe to my channel.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
I'm out of... oh, I'm not out of water.
But I'm out of space in my bladder.
Let's see, let's see, let's see, let's see.
Fudamon...
Fudamon, Fudamon, Fudamon...
Fufufahifu...
Fuu...
Lu...
Mu...
Oh?
I'm searching...
Love Chronicle, Eternal Smile, New Future...
Which one did I sing before?
What did I say?
What song?
I... I think I sung Eternal Snow before.
Did I sing Love Chronicle before?
I wonder why?
Angel Beats is not on here, unfortunately.
I'm sorry.
What's Myself?
Oh, wait, no.
Return to Myself?
Myself?
This one?
Wait, how does this one go?
Why do I like you so much?
No?
Oh?
Inner Universe?
Oh my gosh.
I've tried to get Matara to sing Inner Universe.
It's in Russian.
Hold on, I just want to hear how this one goes.
I know most of them, I think.
How do he character songs?
Oh my gosh, I want to sing the Yukio one.
Myself.
Alright, Ronaldo.
Get out of here.
Yeah, yeah.
Why, why do I like you so much?
My tears are overflowing.
I'll do this one.
I think I know it enough, probably.
Oh, we start with the sad girl.
I don't know.
At that time, there were too many things to lose.
I couldn't sing anything.
I didn't know where I was.
A little distant place.
That was where I should be.
Deep inside your eyes, that day...
I haven't seen you.
I found the sadness.
We weren't the same.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Soja, thank you!
Welcome to membership, too!
Soja,
thank you!
Welcome to membership, too!
Sorry,
I couldn't remember that.
This little kid and his harmonica!
Oh look, he's got his beat on!
Yay, that was Full Moon.
Find Full Moon!
Find Full Moon.
Now, I know people want me to sing...
You get the burning!
From Nadesco.
But I think I'm gonna sing another song.
But that's okay.
If that's okay.
It's one of my favorite songs.
From...
Nadesco!
...
I know this is gonna bring up a ton of results, but...
It should be fine.
You get the burning!
How does it start again?
That's the issue.
I feel like I will remember the...
The...
Just the chorus the best.
You know?
So I'm gonna sing a song from...
From...
From Nadesco.
Instead.
Sung by my favorite character, Ruri.
Called Anata no Ichiban ni Naritai!
I forget everything except the chorus that time.
I love the beginning though.
I will sing it one day.
You get the burning will come eventually.
Don't worry.
One day it will happen.
Let's get a cuter song right now.
Nadesco?
Yes!
Nadesco by Nadesco Yeah, the talent show!
Let's go!
Oh my god a background!
That suits the actual theme!
Oh my gosh!
This song is so sweet!
This song
is so sweet!
Oh my gosh, they're flirting!
Hahaha!
Ships and love!
I still have a couple more songs that I want to sing.
What should we end the
party song?
What should we end the party song?
I still have a couple more songs that I want to sing.
It's sky blue.
Maybe I could try.
Again.
Ah, sheep Burcha.
Ah, sheep
Burcha.
I know what song I want to end on.
I don't think I've ever sung it before but I love this song.
Sorry.
Lots of good suggestions though.
Like I said though, I still have a few more songs, like, I'm gonna try and find this one.
Even though it's Friday the 13th, I haven't done a single spooky song.
I don't know really what a spooky song would be though, right?
I don't know.
But, I want to try this one.
I'll be honest though, I am all in on Fall right now.
I'm like, I know there's still a few more days left of Summer, but I'm like so all in on Fall.
Okay, what I'm going to do...
Because, actually, I'll do the song and then I'll...
No.
Have you ever watched Nadesco Printed Darts?
I have!
I have, I have, yeah.
I own, like, the Dreamcast Nadesco games.
The stuff that takes place in between the Nadesco games.
The Nadesco series, and then the Nadesco movie, you know?
Like, I'm a huge fan of Nadesco.
Have I played them?
No.
Higurashi is spooky.
You are so right!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, alright.
Oh, no, not hiki.
No, not kokorani.
Wait.
I don't want to look up higurashi.
No.
I don't want to look up, like, kai, or, you know, getsu, or sotsu, or whatever.
Okay,
I'm just going to search this.
Which higurashi song do I sing?
Higurashi no nakokorani.
Do I sing...
I believe in what you...
Analogy?
No, not the medley.
Usually these medleys kind of suck.
They're not so fun.
Dear You?
You know what that could replace?
I was going to sing Natsukage, but Dear You could replace...
Could replace it, because it's very... that kind of vibe, right?
They don't have it?
No way!
I'm going to cry.
No!
But it's like...
It's...
I mean, which variation even would we sing, but it's still...
Kami-sama no shin syndrome?
I'm going to cry.
Naraku no Hana.
You know what?
I'll just go.
Let's see.
Since I said I wanted kind of a spooky song, let's go with Higurashi no nakokorani.
Right?
It's kind of spooky.
It's like the spookiest.
It's pretty spooky.
It's pretty...
It's pretty spooky, right?
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Let me type it down.
Whoa!
The moon!
The
13!
The 13!
The moon!
It's easy to read!
How do we say this?
Have a nice day!
Bye!
We were just in the city, what happened?
What
is happening in this video?
I don't know.
Oh, my gosh, you guys, my neck is starting to, like, itch, like, crazy!
Weird!
I'm just going to keep itching it, I'm just going to keep scratching!
It's, like, really itchy!
Oh, my gosh, it's, like, really, really itchy!
Oh, my gosh, it's, like, crazy itchy!
Wow!
Wow, oh, my gosh, my neck has never been so itchy before.
Not the itch.
Do you know Oyashiro-sama?
Yes, I know!
Yeah,
I should drink more water.
Yeah, I should drink more water.
More of the water from the village, right?
Is this a bit?
Are you okay?
Oh, I guess...
For people that don't know, when you get Hinamizawa syndrome, your neck starts to, like, itch a lot.
And it's from the anime that I just sang, Higurashi no Nakakoro ni.
So, you know, it's, like, one of those, you know...
Yeah, the maggots!
The maggots!
Alrighty!
Oh, my gosh, it's been four hours, me singing.
I did not expect to sing this long.
Truly.
But I have one last song I would like to sing.
One last song.
A song that...
Probably I don't sing very well.
But I love singing it because it's so fun.
And I want everybody to sing along if you know it.
What?
What is...
Which...
Actually...
Oh, gosh.
It's, like...
There's, like, a bajillion.
Oh.
Hold on.
Who's the artist?
Oh!
Should I put it in Japanese?
Okay.
Thanks.
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah, Japanese?
Okay.
Thanks!
Yeah.
It'll probably be way easier, right?
Because there's so many English songs.
Yay!
Let's sing!
We are from One Piece!
Yippee!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh,
my gosh.
I did two One Piece songs today.
Thank you guys for coming to my karaoke.
Oh, my gosh.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
The song always gets me so high!
肩押されて一歩リードさ 今度会えたら話すつもりさ それからのことと これからのこと
誰かにアピールできるいいチャンス だって夜はポケットにはないけど ポケットにロマンス それとYou wanna be my friend We are, we are on the cruise.
We are.
We are, we are on the cruise.
Aritake no yume wo kakiatsume.
We are.
We are, we are on the cruise.
See ya later.
See ya, see ya.
Hold on.
See ya, see ya, see ya.
My outro, my outro music.
My outro music.
Thank you guys for the karaoke.
And maybe, I know I did like any song theme this time for in the future.
I'll do, I'll do like, maybe like, you know, 90s theme.
Or early, 90s early 2000.
Or, or like songs you hear often at Anikura.
I want to do an Anikura one.
So that like, I can just do calls to it.
And teach you guys more about calls and stuff like that, you know.
But yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, yeah like, I said 90s, 80s, 90s, 2000s.
So, yeah.
Thank you guys for listening to karaoke.
And we guys had fun.
And I hope you guys have a good night.
A good day.
I hope you guys had a good summer.
Bye.
This is the end of the show.
See ya later.
Bye-bye.
Bye -bye.
Thank you for that.
I'm gonna say bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
I don't wanna leave out the audience.
Bye-bye, everyone.
The show is over, everyone.
See ya later.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye...
I'm walking by.
Can I get behind you, guys?
Can I get behind you, guys, real quick?
Okay.
Don't mind me.
I'm just stepping behind you real quick.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
You're just like...
Okay, that one is like...
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
You're really like...
You're really like blocking my way outta here, okay.
Thank you!
Thank
you!
Ha ha ha ha ha!